the gyro can experience yeah what a
broad range of culture that you've been
exposed to that's that's pretty [ __ ]
cool yeah Nigeria is a strange spot
because I've never I've never been but
when you look at the numbers of
successful immigrants like businessmen
and people that have come over from
Nigeria and how industrious they are and
then you look at how many successful
Nigerian scammers there are it's a wise
very clever place you got the email from
the prince - huh I didn't get it sure I
have but the one I was thinking about
was Jaime was telling me a story
yesterday about a guy who would he sell
they sold a non-existent Bank Airport
Airport the other bank - that's right he
sold a non-existent Airport to a better
there's been several stories over the
last couple of weeks about Nigerian
scammers making big scores yeah there's
one that I think closed down a Brazilian
bank it took so much of their money but
the bank had to show the bank had to
shut down what is it about Nigeria why
are they so good at that a lot a lot of
smart and enterprising people and I
think if that's channeled in the right
way then that's a very good thing well I
think some people obviously there's the
resources are very limited so they're
they're deciding to just go dark and
scam people but as a person who hasn't
been a victim of this it's quite amusing
yeah if you see if you see some of the
stuff that that can get pulled off it's
it's quite impressive it is very much
like men it's actually 330 equivalent to
American dollars three on 30 million it
happened in the 90s though I guess the
story is just now going around okay the
reason but it happened in the 90s which
is what this says con man once sold an
airport that didn't exist for 330
million now for stop and think about
that 330 million in the 90s is probably
like 600 million today or something
[ __ ] bananas
yeah that's larious yeah there's some
there's some crazy stuff that Nigerian
fraudster and con artist Emanuel how do
you suppose how do you pronounce his
last name nwu de woody may be Moody no
say it again Moody I guess something
like that what are you you starting with
a M how do you say uh moody with an N
but Emanuel but how are you doing it
it's it's an N but it's the
pronunciation is a little bit different
say it again
Moody well it sounds to me like you say
Moody no it's it's an N go uh I'm called
weirdly enough that guy's name is two
letters off my actual first name really
yeah my until my first name is in zoo
Bay whoa which is spelled n z ube so
that's actually two letters different so
you just said zoo B would be a little
bit more yeah he's just easy six easier
it's cool it's a cool name - no one no
one has that yeah thank you I've never
heard of this so he pulled off the third
largest con in history by selling a
non-existent airport to a Brazilian bank
for 205 million u.s. dollars before
Nigerian internet scams became
synonymous with your original early
2000s email account mood day to do it
yeah close enough thank you successfully
convinced an unassuming bank manager by
the name of Nelson
Sakaguchi that he was selling a
yet-to-be-built Airport for a price of
330 million dollars as the former
director of the Union Bank of Nigeria
himself Moody was privy to confidential
information that was crucial to him
pulling off his long con oh so he knew
[ __ ] about banking hmm using the
information he imper then impersonated
the governor of Central Bank of Nigeria
at the time Paul okay here's another one
Paul Oguma Oguma Oguma Okuma so you
wouldn't go whoa
it's Okuma Oguma Oguma and connected
with sakaguchi we need steve aoki come
back to inform him of a mouthwatering
deal
Nigeria's plan to build a brand-new
airport in another one Abuja Abuja
Oh Cass the capital to juice it up a bit
for poor sakaguchi moody promised the
head of the Brazilian of the Brazilian
bank a commission feed to the tune of
ten million US dollars if the deal was
approved to get it over the line
Sakaguchi paid 191
in cash as you do and the remainder in
the form of outstanding interest awaited
patiently for the construction of said
airport well Wow that's the kind of
thing you can only pull off once huh
yeah if you get that guy again you're I
saw a guy that got scammed and there was
a documentary about it was it was a
television show rather it was really sad
because he was a dude who was an older
gentleman and looked like he was in his
60s and he was convinced that there was
this woman who was you know is his love
and she lived in Europe and he travelled
there and he was sending her money and
the whole deal and he travelled there
twice to meet her and both times she
couldn't see him both times well but he
still believed and his daughter was like
I don't know what the [ __ ] to do this
guy really believes and you could see
had this lost look in his eye he really
believed that there was a woman over
there that was corresponding with him
back and forth and he was sending her
money sent her a lot of money yeah I
think it was more than $100,000 if I
remember correctly and he really
believed that she was gonna be there for
him and then when you went over there
something came up and I couldn't meet
them and yeah it's weird with stuff like
this I always feel like in some way you
kind of feel sad for the person but in
and out they're kind of like what what
were you thinking how do you bounce back
from that like people hit some lows yeah
people hit some lows in life how do you
bounce back from thinking that there's a
girl in Europe that's gonna be your love
and sending her a hundred thousand
dollars and traveling over there twice
mmm and getting duped both times and
then how do you bounce back from that
and the first thing you should do is not
tell anybody like take take the El
without just in quiet justice just take
it take it quietly and privately and
don't uh don't tell people
his daughter knew about it okay so and
then the camera crew I mean this
[ __ ] brought Cameron home I
don't know why I think the show I very
vaguely remember this and I think it was
about ten years ago I think the show was
all about people that were getting
scammed okay it was about why people get
scammed and
what you know what is it that makes
people believe ridiculous things yeah
but when when it comes to romance and
money those are the two where people get
greedy yeah I was literally gonna say
it's greed it's greed because only
greedy people can fall for some of those
things I mean you see some of those
scams and it'll come through saying okay
I've just inherited 30 million dollars
and I need somebody in the US with a
u.s. bank account to help me out with
this and I'll give you a 10% cut and you
know that should raise a lot of red
flags for anybody who's kind of thinking
with that with a head on straight